café comme ça du café à nos papilles la
route du café semble de plus en plus
sinueuse un chemin qu art sauver
torréfacteur emprunte depuis plus de
trente ans il cherche les arômes en
amérique latine en asie ou encore en
afrique
mais la différence se situe désormais
dans le prix sur le marché mondial qui
ne cessent de flamber une augmentation
de 36% dans les douze derniers mois le
marché se cacher de marché que l'on
pourrait qualifier d' instable parce que
les prix ne cessent de monter
je voudrais qu'à certains égards il est
relativement stable parce que il est
prévisible on n'anticipe pas de baisse
marquée du du cours du café au cours des
deux prochains mois
mais pour avoir sauvé c'est le prix du
transport du café qui laisse un goût
amer
intérieurement ça coûtait 2 mai 5 85
dollars
de l'animation de ce matin à vancouver
de même passé douze mandats en plus
s'ajoute pas d'argent darroch du
producteur ou sumatra et encore moins
dans les poches des producteurs
brésiliens qui en plus doit faire face
aux intempéries ravageuse walkie 20 12
pour certains il n'y aura pas de récolte
avant 2023 avec le récent épisode de gel
qu'a connue le pays
l'impact des changements climatiques est
sans équivoque il se fera sentir sur les
plus petits producteurs
louis filet brouillette a choisi de
s'associer directement avec certains
d'entre eux une démarche plus équitable
à son sens on décide de travailler
directement avec des producteurs pour
assurer 1 h constat chaque année à des
prix qui ont du sens si on regarde les
statistiques actuellement débat loin de
50% les producteurs en amérique latine
qui vendent à perte leur café si les
soubresauts du marché du café n'inquiète
pas encore les consommateurs c'est parce
que des importateurs passent des
commandes sur le long terme avec un prix
fixe regarde la marche et puis on se dit
bon ben c'est être la terre avec le
marché mort quand même
nos demandes sous la table on se protège
pour sa prépa 3 6 mois huit mois ça
dépend mais au-delà de cette période
sommes-nous prêts à payer plus cher
notre café tout en valeur tout a un prix
et en os qu'on paye pour j'aime vraiment
le café alors on
je vais me passer d'autres choses
peut-être mais pas du café droits de
l'homme on peut considérer ici à cette
radio canada à saint sauveur